oh my goodness hello everybody
today hi Ellen yep she brought me up she
brought me a gift I love Ellen I did not
bring any televisions though
I apologize but you're you're an egot
winner so you don't need to bring
anything you just show up and bless us
uh you've been you know
sometimes we trade favors in the
business and Kelly has been on my show
yes can I talk trailer talk
Channel talk
has a way smaller budget than Kelly
Clarkson show we don't have any mics we
uh we don't have proper seating for our
guests we only aired on IG TV
but we do sing songs together you do and
you have all these people and I missed
Terry Crews the other day in the
compound at the voice I was so sad I
love him we sang anniversary by Tony
Toni Toni you know oh my gosh I love him
he's fun fantastic I love him okay but
wait I do have a question though because
I feel like you'll travel every time I
see you at the voice you're like we just
got back from Japan we just got back
from Russia we just got back and I'm
like geez like how are Christy and the
kids how are y'all doing everybody's jet
lagged yes
we just got back from Thailand
oh my gosh like I'm telling you it's a
different country like it's not even
like you know somebody's like I went to
Nebraska like something it's like a
whole flight like a whole thing well I
have gigs a lot of times yeah that's
Thailand oh my gosh so Chrissy's mother
is from Thailand uh if you guys want to
follow her on Instagram she's an
instagrammy too
[Applause]
she's pepper tied to on Instagram but
she's originally from Thailand and we
went to visit Thailand for the first
time with the kids they've never been
there to see their grandmother's
Homeland I love it it's beautiful the
food's amazing I ate some crazy things
though oh see I don't do that I
I'll try anything I'll try anything
no okay I won't no
[Music]
[Applause]
guys I'm going